the subaru love promise comes from
loving leadership i stopped by subaru of
las vegas the sponsors of this segment
to introduce you to the man behind that
promise
you know i always love coming down to
subaru of las vegas and telling you guys
what's going on in the community and
what they're doing with their amazing
cars but
i never get to introduce you to burton
hughes himself so i want to get to know
you i want to educate everybody about
the guy behind the love here at subaru
of las vegas so
what inspired you to get into the
automotive industry and just kind of
tell us your journey before you got here
well rocky when i was 10 years old i had
an argument with god
i loved cars from a little kid i love
cars and but my dad was a pastor and i
knew i had
a calling to ministry as well
and and so i thought i had won the
argument and i went into the car
business at 19 years old but then i
ended up
studying for pastoral ministry and and i
have actually been doing both for over
30 years and i think you know what is a
minister it's someone who serves
and so
that
is the core value that i that i lead
with here and and it's really what
drives uh the love promise as we live it
out on a daily basis at subaru of las
vegas incredible and for those who don't
know how do you guys incorporate that
here at subaru las vegas you know we get
involved in so many great great um
initiatives and you know we're right at
the back to school time of year and so
we've got several things happening uh
for for our students for our educators
but you know what one of the things that
really um stirs my heart is
you know the nevada nevada childhood
cancer foundation does a camp every year
for
critically ill children and and they do
it at torino ranch on the back side of
mount charleston
for two weeks 200 kids that are pretty
much locked up in a hospital get to come
out and they get to just enjoy life
and to do that every year is just an
amazing thing now how does that attitude
trickle down to your team and your
employees here at subaru las vegas you
know there were so many that signed up
for camp cartwheel it's called there are
so many i thought are we gonna have
anybody left at the dealership
you know it's it's just
doing the things that we do in the
community it it just spreads and we
realize giving is so much better than
just receiving we have a subaru of las
vegas read to me book drive we're
collecting
new and gently used books here all
through the month of august it's it's
going to go to spread the word nevada
great organization uh that we've
partnered with for for years uh and
maybe just to mention that we have
partnered uh with the marion b earl
elementary school for the month and uh
we're gonna be uh we've committed to
giving them twelve thousand five hundred
dollars for the educators to spend on
their students you give so much love to
the community but also you give so much
love to your customers i think that
maybe you know the fact that the
inventories are extremely low but you
know what we're still
we are ordering cars people can special
order cars super modus finance is
actually locking in rates if you order a
car and it takes a little longer to get
and now you know where that subaru love
promise comes from right from burton
hughes thank you for for helping our
community and having your customers
leave here with safe vehicles
and so much love thank you rocky
thank you to findlay subaru of las vegas
for sponsoring that segment find them
right there on roy horn way and for more
information just call 702-495-2100
and don't forget their special offer 2.9
financing for well-qualified buyers for
up to 48 months on select 2022 models